et
[Musique]
elisabeth enfance et leur maman passe
après midi au square
[Musique]
ça y est ça ne rate pas d'où elles
foncent commence attaque il écrit des
chiens
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant tiens toi tranquille
ac red one tomber tu étais qu est-ce qu
il faire mais ils attachent à la pelote
de laine de maman à tous mes tours 15
tout
ayvaz m'arrêterai de chiens tiers sur
l'autre bout maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez c'est la statue du général qui
a vu quelle famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car tu dois préparer une bêtise bon
maintenant ça suffit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est vraiment insupportable ces gamins
bombe à froid ça va te calmer maintenant
ne te plains pas sous les animaux se
venge toutes les misères que tu leur as
fait ciblées
[Musique]
bon cette fois écouté voit tout et tout
ne soyez pas méchant avec les animaux
[Musique]
sont gentils dans cette famille mais un
peu fourre vous ont rendu compte aux
frais des grains à watou et on allait
souvenez vous soyez gentil avec eux à
minuit
d'accord au revoir
et
on